so thank you very much ever
for coming we're delighted that you're
here and we're delighted to offer you
some intriguing thoughts and discussion
on an important issue not only for
technology but also for the environment
my name is Oswald Schmitz oz for short
I'm the director of the Yale Institute
for biospheric studies gets for short
yips is sort of an umbrella institution
here at Yale incentivising
interdisciplinary or at least
cross-disciplinary research and training
in the environmental sciences one of the
nice jobs of yips because it's basically
people liken it to a giant foundation
within Yale I get to give out a lot of
money to incentivize things or do
special projects and things and this is
this is certainly one of those what we
like to do in yips is occasionally have
gatherings like the one we are having
tonight and and tomorrow to really
discuss issues of importance and
significance and it's nice to be able to
incentivize that and bring people from
outside and across campus to to sort of
meet and discuss and ultimately really
try and find some resolution to some of
the reigning environmental problems so
and that's one of the exciting parts of
the job this is more broad than the
purview of Yids because it involves you
know humanist perspectives and
everything so this is not just sponsored
by UPS it's also sponsored by the
interdisciplinary Center for Bioethics
at Yale and also the Frankie Center for
humanities and science and it's a nice
partnership and it's also again an
example of how we can gather resources
at Yale to really sort of think about
the broader picture and and the bigger
issues I'm not going to say much more
because this is not my show this is
really a show by a young woman who has
had a lot of energy and passion to
really wrestle with this issue and she's
she and I have been meeting almost
weekly since the fall to really talk
about this and get this off the ground
so there's a lot of planning in here and
a lot of hard work and and a lot of
passion and that passion is Natalie
Kohler dr. Natalie Cole fleur who is
currently in the Yale Medical School
and with that Natalie the floor is yours
[Applause]
can you can you hear me hi thank you
everyone for being here and accepting
our invitation to join us in this very
important conversation I actually
struggled to figure out what I wanted to
say when I was going to have these short
welcome remarks I have a lot in my head
and in my heart that I've been thinking
about what this issue it's a really
interesting issue and so I couldn't
really figure out what I wanted to say
and then I realized finally last night
that really this isn't about me getting
up here and talking about gene-editing
to you what I think about it this is me
getting up here and creating a space for
us and that's really what this vision
for this whole summit has been is
creating space opening space and and
with that we wanted to create a space
where we can bring together people from
all backgrounds and disciplines to be
able to talk about this really important
and complex issue because this is a
really complex issue it's complex at the
genetic level where you have genetic
networks that are interacting with each
other and we're trying to change those
genes it's complex at the ecological
level where we might be releasing
organisms out into the environment that
have mutations that we've we've
initiated when it's complex at the
societal level because there's these
value systems that get that need to be
tapped into there's people's ideas of
what's right and what's wrong that
varied and it also brings up these
questions of really what is it to be
human how do we fit into this greater
space of our earth what does it mean
what is natural what is unnatural so
these are really complex things
and complex issues and they require
really complex solutions not complicated
solutions but complex solutions
solutions that engage everyone and bring
all the inputs and components together
to be able to really start to figure out
how to grapple with this issue and
that's what we're trying to create a
space where everyone can come together
from their different backgrounds and
join and discuss this and that also
requires something a level of complexity
on each of us as an individual and what
we invite you to do and what's important
is that you come into the space in your
entirety in your totality and everything
that makes you and that's something I
struggled us a lot as a scientist I felt
like as a scientist I had to leave
certain things at the door I had to
leave my spirituality I didn't leave my
values my subjectivity that didn't
really help me as sort of a scientist as
I could have been and that's something I
think we all need to know is to bring
our whole being our whole selves to the
story and that's our wisdom that's our
individual wisdom and knowingness and
from that individual wisdom we can
create collective wisdom and I think
that collective wisdom is what's so
important in this issue we find that
space that magical space where all of us
can come together and try to steer this
technology responsibly and in a way that
really comes up with effective solutions
that move us into an elevated future and
so that's what we're trying to do here
they really so grateful that all of you
have comes as joy in this conversation
I'm also so grateful for having had the
opportunity to work with Oz and Gibbs to
put this together for the financial
support of Gibbs as well as admonishment
ins at Yale and to display Science
Center for Bioethics with Steven Latham
who is one of our committee mysterion
committee members there as well as the
Frankie program in humanities and
Sciences we've also have great input
from Missha Simonov who's also on er
steering committee he's a dual degree
major graduate student in school of
architecture in the school forestry
environmental studies as well as Vivian
Vigliotti was at the back there she's
been our communications and web design
guru with
her you wouldn't have known this is
happening so that was very important as
well as all the volunteers that have
come and helped today and throughout and
people that have helped shape the vision
for this summit this has been definitely
very much a collective effort I also
want to give a very big thank you to the
L Peabody Museum they've allowed us to
use this space for this event now as
well as for the cocktail hour which will
follow in the Great Hall and Jonathan
Rohnert and particular has been really
instrumental in helping with logistics
of getting this event off the ground and
well that's about it I wanted to talk
about just generally the program so
we'll have the keynote talks tonight and
then tomorrow again we'll be reconvening
at 9:00 9:00 a.m. for breakfast talks
starting at 9:30 at Rosenfeld Hall we'll
have a series of short talks from
ranging from geneticists to ethicists to
architects to synthetic biologists to
regulatory policy experts it's going to
be a really great discussion again
tomorrow so I hope you can join us again
there and and now I would like to
introduce our two keynote speakers for
this evening
and I really just loving that the two of
them are going to be up here to speak
with you because they really complement
each other and a really interesting and
wonderful way I think our first talk
will be given by dr. James Collins he's
come from Arizona State University and
he's the heezy let's see I'm sorry I
always forget the full name good well he
just basically the professor of Natural
History and environmental studies at ASU
but he actually studies host-pathogen
interactions and with the specific focus
on Mississippians and how that said
direct populations in ecology
he's also was the director of population
biology and physiological ecology
program at the NSF from 85-86 as well as
the NSF's assistant director of
biological sciences and he's really also
helped contribute to shaping the space
of ecological ethics and really looking
again outside and broader than just the
sciences to start communications about
how we how we do science and how we look
at ecology
he will be giving a talk called ultra
nature by gene-editing
we can but should we and then Emma Maris
will follow Emma Maris is a author and
writer was written for a variety of news
outlets including the New York Times and
nature wired and she also has written a
really wonderful book which came out in
2011 called rambunctious garden which
really started to kind of for me reshape
the way that we could approach
environmentalism and I think if you will
kind of touch upon the same kind of
ideas of how we interact with nature and
how we might need to change those
interactions to make for a sustainable
future so without further ado we'll
bring up James for the first talk join
all right all right well it's a pleasure
to be here
Natalie thanks so much for that terrific
introduction I appreciate it we'll do it
great so let me get us started here with
three numbers one hundred thirty-eight
thousand seventy percent and two minutes
138 thousand people seventy percent of
them are children and two minutes
according to the nature according to
target malaria in 2015 forty thirty
eight thousand people died from malaria
that number varies a little bit as I've
looked at it from 350 thousand to the
four hundred and thirty eight thousand
seventy percent of those deaths were due
out work and children and that figured
out to about every two minutes the child
dies as a result of malaria now I want
to give you a question with this
information in the back of your head
actually in the front of your head right
now and here is the first question this
is not an exam but you can think it
through so if I gave you a technology
that could eradicate a species of
mosquito that caused that sort of impact
as far as human populations are
concerned what would you do there are
your three choices in front of you right
now now my pieces that I want to explore
with you this afternoon and explore with
us this afternoon is that there are
genetic technologies being developed
that can exact reach into this space
that can help mitigate potentially that
sort of impact as far as human
populations are concerned but like a
number of technologies and in fact
technologies
general as genetic technologies in
particular have them developed when you
get into this sort of space it begins to
put a very sharp edge on a number of
things and in particular the ethical
legal and social implications of this
sort of work the sort of research that
can enable us to reach into that sort of
situation and so I want to walk us
through and help think about what this
looks like today and how we might
eventually think about this sort of
problem so to put this in perspective
the sort of genetic technologies which
we hear so much about today are new and
they're shiny and they're bright and
they're just absolutely terrific but in
her a relatively recent book Helen Curie
tells us the story of biotechnology
tells us a story of biotechnology and
emphasizes Flora's the fact that
thinking relative to manipulating genes
or at least manipulating inheritance
goes way back in the depth of the 20th
century the first decade of the 20th
century as a matter of fact there were
thoughts about how might you manipulate
genetic material using things such as
radiation using a chemical called
colchicine to actually change the
information in organisms then she walked
us through this history reminding us
that there's an arc of change associated
with what we now know as as
biotechnology that stretches from the
first decade of the 20th century up
until the present
so what I'll talk about today and what
in fact we'll talk about for the next
two and a half days is part of an
evolving story it's part of a story as
far as discovery is concerned it's part
of a story in terms of application of
that stuff discovery in terms of
biotechnology and it's a part of
a debate that's gone on now for the
better part of 120 years in terms of how
we can take this information use it and
move on now the thing that's happening
though today is that the technologies
especially the ones that I'm going to
talk about have become so precise and
some ways so easy to use that they
really begin to put a sharp edge on this
conversation between scientists
ethicists legal scholars social
scientists causing us to need to think
about these problems as
multidisciplinary transdisciplinary
solutions that are probably going to be
integrated they have to be integrative
and the question is how to move ahead in
that sort of space so on the same
website of project malaria we seek
target material science they propose the
possible solution in October of 2016
could gene drives would it be possible
to use gene drives to tackle malaria in
Africa this is an intriguing possibility
that still remains an intriguing
possibilities as far as a way to reach
into these systems and have an immediate
and interesting effect so let's talk
about what a gene drive is in order to
get our footing there and I'm going to
walk us through two cases one involving
gene drives very directly and excellent
involving a related form of genetic
modification and then we'll get to the
point of alright how might we make some
decisions in this case well what would
you need to know what would you want to
be thinking about in order to make
decisions in this sort of space so
here's what a genie drive is
read it for you but the point that's
relevant is this notion of guaranteeing
transmission of a gene from one
generation to the next so let's talk a
little bit about that what that means
so in this audience you have men and
women the ratio of men to women across
the population our population at large
is 50/50 50% males 50% females at first
on average there are as many boys as
they are girls so we talk about the gene
let's say the gene from maleness being
transmitted with a frequency equal to
the gene for females and that's because
males are typically XY chromosome one
does X Y from sum is X comes from two as
well they're paired and then for women
it's xx and so when you meet you wind up
with a 50:50 sex ratio that falls out of
that now the notion of guaranteeing
transmission to the next generation
would be a situation in which for
example males make all the Y's bearing
sperm only Y bearing sperm and if women
continue to make all the x's that means
with each each reproductive reproductive
event you get old emails X Y XY X Y all
emails from one generation to the next
if it were the case that you could have
every male make lonely flies by
Barentsburg technology I'm going to talk
to you about now this notion of a gene
drive and do just that or at least in
principle can do just that and it rests
on this bit of molecular biology or it's
partially on this it's a term or at
least a word an acronym you may have
heard when you go to your next cocktail
party you can tell them about clustering
regulate this very short palindromic
repeats and they really really be
intrigued or asked you to
one of the outcomes is going to be the
possibility but the imagery that goes
along with this notion here is first off
the imagery associated with a scissors
that can cut the in heaven and the other
sort of imagery that's used in
connection with CRISPR is the notion of
a word processor cutting copying and
pasting new information into the genome
cutting copying and pasting let's see
how that might work so let's say we have
a mouse we've got a pair of chromosomes
where I'm going to have two chromosomes
in this mouse that makes it brown and
we'd like that Mouse to be green so we
construct a bit of DNA DNA that bit of
DNA has three components to it it's got
the change that you want so we're going
to cause this mouse to be a little bit
green we're going to need something to
guide our new information to where we
want it to be in a chromosome of this
house and we're going to have this
CRISPR cast minor we're going to CRISPR
we have a big whirring up here that's
the part that does the cutting
so here's what happens you have a
scissor you need a guide make a space
move the new information and our mouse
is now green we've introduced the
genetic material to turn that round that
would have shown that brown mouse begins
to breathe it has green eyes furthermore
because we still have the cutter in the
system the one chromosome reaches over
and cut the other chromosome and
replicates that fraction of the genome
into it so now we have a mouse that's
green and it has two chromosomes
carrying the same information make
agreements we're going to breathe that
green mouse with another brown mouse
cutting happens moving happens and you
wind up then with now green lights
furthermore the green mice have the same
chromosome they're bearing the same
genetic material man and this goes on
from generation to generation until by
the fifth generation we have only green
lights only grievances now if that the
genetic material that I moved over said
make the developing embryo on the whole
and by the time I get to the fifth
generation all my my sermons that green
in this case they're all men and if
they're all males and essentially
reproducing species it's a population
doing to extinction and if that trait
moves out of that population and if the
other population you have what's called
a global gene Drive which means you
could drive a species to extinction okay
that's a technology this technology has
been developed now and has been
demonstrated in the laboratory and
Drosophila small fly it's been
demonstrated in a species of yeast and
it's also been demonstrated in two
species of mosquitoes all in the
laboratory not in the food a couple of
facts about gene drugs that we're
keeping in mind they occur in many
species the reality of driving genes has
been known for better part of 100 years
the difference now is having the
technology to be able to harness those
natural biological processes towards the
sort of ends that I'm suggesting gene
drives are designed to spread and
persist so unlike a manipulation that
Monsanto might do where it wants to keep
it in a particular farm or cluster upon
this is designed to spread and it will
move beyond boundaries of them those in
the laboratory sexual reproduction is
required and a relatively short
generation plan so when are going to
these gene drives in humans
there's no point 20-year generation time
we're shorter in some societies it's not
what you want you wanted to be able to
turn quickly in these populations in
order to convert them as I said from
green lights or from males and females
to all males I had a chance to look back
at Silent Spring and indeed here's the
language that Rachel Carson used for
Biological control so a gene drives a
kind of biological control it is in a
way that she could case you could so
elegantly put it's the notion of turning
the strength of the species against
itself
it's the idea to use the drive of an
insect life force the drive of an insect
life force to destroy it it's just this
elegant way of putting what this biology
is all about now the thinking and range
eyes on the upside in terms of this
technology is you can apply it in a
variety of different ways think about it
as I suggested early on to be able to
manipulate populations of organisms that
are bearing infectious diseases think
about it as being able to remove exotic
species from island populations where
endangered species of birds are
threatened to think about it in terms of
being able to reverse herbicide
resistance in agricultural situations
and make those plants once again
susceptible to herbicide so these are
the contexts in which is being thought
about to use these genes and in fact it
has attracted a lot attention
the New York Times and the story has had
multiple stories actually on this
technology on the use of emotion of
using it against infectious diseases and
more species and in crop species it has
attracted the attention of conservation
biologists so when there's article by
Michael specters and a couple
now in in The New Yorker he's arguing
and conservation biologist some are
agreeing with him to use gene drives to
remove mosquitoes from Hawaii where
they're an introduced species anyway and
they're driving the extinction of Native
Hawaiian birds in fact the evidence
suggests that or even a number of
species extinct it's actually in his
words exciting information for
conservation biologists and in fact in a
recent report there's a series of
workshops that are happening to think
about the possibility of driving
mosquitoes out of Hawaii in exotic
species and this is a way forward and
even in the scientific community we have
a leading individual endorsing the
prospect of driving these malaria
bearing mosquitoes or at least one
species of them to extinction
it's also been picked up in a popular
press in some ways we might describe as
a little bit more worried or you do
begin to get on a slippery slope anyway
if it's mosquitoes today all the
mosquitoes today ident I would get a
positive vote in Connecticut if it were
the ticks that are bearing Lyme disease
tomorrow for example but where do you
stop once you're on that slope and who
gets to make those decisions and where
do we have those conversations finally
you can get one step even more alert is
that were possible and begin to talk
about an extinction machine here in
terms of the MIT biotech review
classifying this as an extinction
machine so here we have a case where
we've got this genetic technology you
want to reach into natural systems and
Emmas going to help us understand what
natural means
going to reach into these systems
and a she ate these changes so that's
question one so you can go to your
cocktail party remember you're going to
talk about crisper and you're going to
talk about should I use this technology
here's question two let's say I gave you
a technology capable of bringing species
back from extinction
so I'm not driving an extinct now we're
going to bring them back and what would
you do you choices it's an open book
exam so some examples here would include
the American chestnuts so the exact
definition of the extinction moves
around a bit so for some this is an
example for the extinction for others
it's an example of genetic recipe and
the facts and a moment I'll show you the
two of them tied together so the
American chestnut you can still find
individuals but they're not the canopy
trees that they were in this northeast
and deciduous forest in which we sit
well they were basically remnants of
themselves and there are a couple
different ways in which genetic
modification is being tried in these
organisms
one is through chance transgenics so
William Powell is over in SUNY Syracuse
who's using transgenic there are other
groups that are breeding American
chestnuts the Chinese chestnuts where
the fungus originally evolved the blind
originally roll and are trying to breed
resistance with the lines of American
chestnut so that's one way to do it but
the other way to do it and it's that's
being tried to know the species as well
so in the middle we have the lovely
black footed ferret and they are down to
a small number of individuals but
they're again our research labs thinking
about reading it to be putting it
through these populations genetic
capacity to resist the infections are
killing these populations but on either
side left and right we have even more
iconic
examples of the notion of the extinction
on one side is a passenger pigeon where
there's a program in place now to try to
bring back passenger pigeons using the
DNA of individuals that are present in
for example museum collections such as
this Museum here and or the notion of
bringing back Wilda mammals so this can
be taking to the point where something
you may have seen in the Atlantic a
little while ago the notion of
Pleistocene Park where you can bring
back or the thinking is to bring back
some of these organisms and have them
once again present on the steps the High
Arctic where they once existed there are
a number of individuals that are
thinking very hard about this thinking
hard about it in very interesting ways
dr. Beth Shapiro for example is being
very clear about in how hard it is in
fact impossible probably to bring back a
mammoth as such you can get this amount
of DNA out of some of the historical
records but you can't get the whole
genome but you could put bits of mammoth
DNA into elephant and a particular Asian
elephant DNA which is what George chirp
of church in his lab are doing at
Harvard University so you can begin to
get contemporary organisms with traits
comparable to woolly mammoths that might
have a better chance of surviving in the
hierarchy and Stewart Brand who has
thought a lot about this notion of the
extinction has made this point here
which really does begin to push this
notion of technology again up against
the ethical legal and social
implications of this sort of work
and raises the prospect of this being a
moral obligation on the part of
contemporary society to do something in
terms of bringing these organisms back
and Mike Archer
Michael Archer has made an even stronger
case that if we're responsible he argues
that we have a moral obligation to try
to bring back such a species interface
of ethical legal social science humanism
how do these things come together in
order to make a decision in moving ahead
so the other thing to keep in mind for
your cocktail party is that when you
hear the word extinction I'd love for
you to think of that what sort of
extinction this individual is thinking
about 99 plus percent of the species
that have ever been on the planet of
gone extinct we can call that natural
extinction if you want there are these
genetic technologies being developed
that have the capacity to do deliberate
extinction and then there's the notion
of bringing organisms back the
extinction the extinction can mean a
different variety of different things
and can play itself out
in a variety different ways so let me
now go to this third part it's off and
talk about okay we can but should we and
how do you think about this kind of
problem how do not out lightly think
about it now in the United States when
you have a complex problem like that one
place you can go with the National
Academy of Sciences and indeed the
National Institutes of Health and the
foundations of the National Institutes
of Health came to the National Academy
in 2014 and said you'd really like to
know some things about teen drivers
could you put together a committee for
us to take a look at it i curvature the
board life sciences for the Academy and
they asked me to chair the Committee on
co-chaired the committee
reading Elizabeth tightening who called
his deeply trained in ethics and the two
of us co-chaired the committee before
the Academy of Sciences and what the NIH
asked us to think about were these four
questions what may be the unintended
consequences of something like chain
joins do we know enough to use them
should they be used and even should they
be developed and how do we decide these
sorts of things so we took a look at the
science and looking at the science we
decided that the science was not
sufficiently well-developed to be able
to recommend releasing gene drives into
the environment that we did not know
enough about the ecology ecosystems
biology the evolution of these systems
to be able to make the kinds of
predictions needed to develop the models
yet to be able to justify releasing
these children but we did argue that the
research should continue the benefits of
this sort of research are just so
significant emotionally being able to
lift the disease burden on some
populations of human is just so
significant that it made a lot of sense
to be able to go ahead with this work
but we also recommended that if this
work is to go ahead it has to be firmly
grounded on values values as we looked
at it here complicated evolving beliefs
in our lives and the world at large and
these values have to be discussion of
values that have the things that have to
be protected Fosters and indeed even
accorded these values has to be coupled
with the idea of engaging the public and
engaging the public at different levels
so if you're going to eliminate
mosquitoes and Greenwich Connecticut
Connecticut you want to talk to the
people in Greenwich but you might also
in fact you really want to talk to the
people here too especially if you're
going to do with children and maybe even
the people in New York and
then you can go to even larger publics
that might have a stage in thinking
about whether or not this technology
should be developed and then used we
also thought a lot about governance and
the idea that these gene drives are
presenting important and interesting
environmental and security challenges as
well as benefits so governance of these
gene drives is going to be important and
furthermore we were also thinking about
the notion of anticipatory governance
the idea of thinking hard about a
technology and its implications before
it's fully developed and ready to be
released you really want to have thought
about it as deeply as you can beforehand
in anticipation of reducing and we saw
this as a way to help mitigate risk we
saw this away as a way to be
precautionary and we argued that there
were ways to be precautious but also
consistent with supporting science so
it's not the precautionary principle in
the sense that you just don't move ahead
if you don't know where to go but rather
this has to be an active process of
deciding where you might want to go how
you might want to get there can you get
there
what are the issues that need to be
dealt with in thinking this through and
the imagery of Science magazine views
for us for this particular article
anyway was the notion of left-hand side
as you're looking at it places not to go
right hand side blinking yellow lights
be cautious but we could think about how
to get there now if I'm going to make an
argument consistent with a good
rhetorical argument I'm going to give
you the counter argument and the counter
argument is that just don't go there
these two distinguished individuals in
fall of 2016 at the international
meeting for needed conservation of
science conservation of nature made the
case that you shouldn't go there in
terms of teen drivers it's just too
risky we don't know enough and this sort
of technology is not something that we
want to use in the natural world in a
larger sense there's a big argument
about the degree of which we want to be
reaching into manipulating natural
systems if technology helps us save the
wilderness for the MIL wilderness fills
you now there is a very definite view
that there are parts of the world we
just don't want to be touching in terms
of the use of these technologies and
what gets the count of those parts of
the world is a big discussion in and of
itself so to wrap it up you see this
interface between scientific freedom and
responsibility the freedom to move ahead
on the part of scientists to develop the
kinds of things that could be immense
benefits as far as society is concerned
but you wind up needing to deal with
advanced issues related to
responsibility we have the notion of
driving a species extinct mosquitoes
let's trade it off against using that as
a way to mitigate an immense burden of
disease as far as human populations are
concerned where do you strike that
balance and how do we decide how to
strike that balance and in a larger
sense is this our view of nature in
terms of a place where we visit leave
the fewest footprints possible and then
come away from it or do we have a few
amazed nature that is much more complex
a view of nature that comes to us in
pieces that is really a jigsaw puzzle
for us to put together solve there are
pieces still missing piece that we can
think about is building in and how we
building and how we do it and what our
view of nature is
is going to affect all those kinds of
things as we go forward from here
so my last thought would be something
along the following lines if you go to
Washington DC and you go to the far
northern part of Georgetown you'll find
the library there in which you can walk
in and see chiseled on the side of
Dumbarton Oaks its mission or part of
its mission and part of its mission goes
to clarify an ever-changing present and
inform the future with its wisdom so it
seems to me as we think about these
complexities and the interface between
these sorts of genetic mechanisms and
our ecosystem we can do not much better
than thinking along those lines
clarified its ever-changing present and
use our information our vision to inform
the future for our children and our
grandchildren with just a much as much
wisdom as we can emerging from this sort
of work thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]